nhanh đầy đươi và tháng 3, cho bối cảnh yêu cầu định tiếp tục tăng theo đàn phục quối sản xuất thình suán và một tiêu tăng triv hiện tầy ở mức cao,
nhé vụ bảo đam điện, vẫn được đặt ở mức ước tiên cao.
Tập bằng yêu cầu các đơn vị thủ điện theo dõi sát tình hình thủ tiếp thủy văn and thòn hủ đập,
và phối hợp để khai thá hiệu quả mùi nước.
Tên nhà máy nhé điện phải chủ đập trình bị như liệu vật tương thiết yêu,
tăng cường kiểm tra thí vị và suy chi tùn khó theo định mức,
ở bò đam và nạn toàn liên tục, kể cơ phí sảy ra thình tài hoặc sản đặt sau thông.
Các tổng tý công ty định lực cũng được yêu cầu làm việc biệt khách hàng xử dục định lớn,
nên xây dẫn phương án dịch truyền điều trình phụ tài trong trường hợp nâng nắm kéo dài.
Đồng thời tăng cử giữ báo các đồng của định mặt trời máy nhé,
sây diện và các nguồn định phân táng tới và nạn hệ thống.
Chúng tháng bây hệ thống định cũng chữ đo động của các báo số một và các đường lụ quả sản lượng đất tại khu vực nơi tây bắc.
Hôm nay, các bạn bận bận nạn toàn không sản ra sự cố.
IVN và tổng tý định lực mình bắt đong,
đồng ý đậm như lực phương tiện khá phục cố trên lối phân phối,
khói phục các biển cho các kháng biển hồn.